I mean teaching them trying to teach
them attempting that is is the biggest
challenge that I'm facing these days I
don't know be anyone who has kids can
relate to that but but I barely pass
school myself and now I'm expected to be
a teacher and teach for my children you
know math and so on which is by the way
evolved and changed even for an
eight-year-old of those texting with my
daughter's teacher and I was like what
didn't do it this way and it's like a
lot Jones you know so it's we were in a
good place I'm sort of decided that
we're all going to come out of this my
family anyway just a little bit dumber a
little bit behind
just just accept that buta my lack of
teaching skills that's the outcome but
if it was a movie on the other hand you
know I could I could you know be teacher
in a movie I could Good Will Hunting my
way through the process
[Laughter]
not in real life
unfortunately hey listen whenever you're
on the show I always ask you about a
Thor's hammer and you always say oh
that's in my house in Australia you're
in your house in Australia do you have
the hammer is it really there oh the
hammer you mean this one
yeah oh very impressive after time I
don't even you know I sort of forget
where I put them I don't really have
them that that that close to me and so
it's yeah got some breaker to turn up
dude any badges small yeah they go
everywhere with me basically
[Music]